it's time before
he bides this episode is brought to you
by Verizon Wireless
I got a look at and turns out it was
benign - movie fights live we are what
hast thou wrong I gotta give a shout-out
to all the fools in Ala Nation hashtag
out nation where Michael hooligans at
Percival the owl and all that stuff
alright we got an awesome movie fight
say a big jam-packed fully loaded movie
by our fighters first off
oh this gentleman is the managing editor
of fandom and he is an all-around movie
Brainiac Eric Goldman
thanks guys I think this is my third
movie fight so we'll see how it goes you
know don't uh don't play possum or
anything you uh you come in and you do
the damn thing yeah like you drop the
hammer at that first one was at a
convention yeah yeah yeah cool shirt by
the way I like that a musical next up
she is a host for El Rey nation a member
of the sketch comedy group night church
welcome to the party Vanessa great
[Music]
oh and another cool t-shirt right
animator classic pulpy heart love it
awesome
Vanessa excited to have you excited to
be here and I'm always excited to sit
across either the movie fights table or
the dinner table from my biological
father and you know from all over the
place
Scott ma'am my son Nate it's great to
see you and again I am your father
yeah I remember the mode we're on Maury
and came out with the DNA test you are
the father so excited to be back here on
movie fight it's a great seat both of
you Eric in the nest so deciding these
fights will be myself and the Dan kin
couch full of dance Dan Merle what's
going on brother do well how are you
doing Oh real good real good
you ready tickets to the fact zone today
I will do my best and oh I'm so excited
that we have just an amazing lady but
also in the capacity of just being a
conduit for the people the voice of the
people Daniel Radford - please tell us
what's going on
we are live today which means I am back
in my capacity as the voice of the
people as per usual after everyone has
given their initial answers the polls
will go up so you will have until right
around you know the topic is about to
end for you to put in your votes and
that vote is a tiebreaker vote so if
everybody here if we can't get our stuff
together then you become the arbiter or
one of the one of the arbiters of that
round I will also be checking for any
like coal comments other ideas alternate
answers means any of that stuff
dank memes chat go ahead and find us on
movie fights live the hashtag and we'll
see you there we're really excited if
you have any questions about how the
poll works paying someone in the chat or
click on the description down below yeah
post those down
saying Billy beers in the booth
very exciting yes post those dank memes
and then DM me those stank meme I don't
know what that is okay so we have five
main round questions five speed round
questions and we determine this it's the
first person we had a little
back-and-forth about this the last
episode but it's the first person to six
points is our winner
first person to six points that's what
we decided right before we went live all
right you guys ready to jump into the
fun do this Billy is there a sick-ass
package to drop
Thank You Thor Thank You Thor you
Ragnarok okay here is the okay so
there's a major Disney film dropping
this weekend opening up frozen to so
we're asking you in honor of that the
best animated Disney villain who is it
all man so many good ones to choose from
hoo-wee best animated Disney Villains so
we'll get some opening statements and
started off with Eric Goldman no one
fights slickest on and no one villain
eise's villains will say villain eyes is
like gaston that's what i got to go with
the thing about gaston that stands out
to me is subversion is at the time
disney villains were pretty obviously
villains the moment they walked on
screen here you have the archetype of a
hero he's strong he's dashing the town
loves him but guess what you shouldn't
trust him
it showed you a lot about don't trust
the surface of things there could be
other things going underneath the fact
that he is so insidious the fact that he
is trying to get sort of the mob rule
behind him the fact that he is the devil
in sheep's clothing because he is just
like the guy in town the guy everyone's
cheering on but no he's actually a
really really nasty guy I think Gaston
really stands out because he took
everything you kind of knew about what a
disney film was and what these people
look like and really flipped it on its
head alright flipping the script Eric
Scott gives you thumbs up Vanessa
well if Gaston is dashing then Ursula is
thick with two C's not only that but
she's a villain that has already at the
beginning of the film established she's
already won
look at how many souls that she's
collected every villains been defeated
but she's been getting away with it for
a long time not only that she's
convincing she manages to convince Ariel
and everyone around her that she's good
that she's reformed that she's a better
person now before snatching her once
again and honestly unless your villains
are aquatic dwelling you can't even
really mess with her salon or a turf
without drowning so boom don't mess job
tonight
yeah I see Scott strategy all right
Scott who do you like okay so see the
reason I seek great job because none of
you can top scar from The Lion King this
is the 1994 Lion King just I just wanted
to say bite so scarf first of all his
name is scar scar right there signifies
some sort of bloodshed that is about to
take place in this movie I'm a lot of
bloodshed does take place in this movie
you have a character that murdered his
brother banished his nephew this let and
his entire kingdom be destroyed all
because he was spurned because he was
not chosen to be the king this movie The
Lion King it is both biblical and it is
Shakespearean things that no other
Disney animated movie has had probably
since Snow White in the Seven Dwarfs all
right well fact check that and perhaps
fight it out everybody these are cool
villains too but they're so transparent
I mean scar just look at him look at the
company he keeps with the hyenas
Ursula's got her eels
you know Gaston has just got a full name
of food I hanging out with him you
wouldn't suspect him he is so much more
coming in from underneath that where
people are not looking at him whereas at
scar just projects villainy yes he kind
of gets by because he's a family member
but people no not really trust him
Gaston is just way more insidious as far
as getting an entire town you were
talking about Ursula yes she you know
can get people to follow her but she
can't you get an entire town to follow
all screaming kill the Beast that is the
cult of personality that is the cult of
Gaston and whatever it is he has it and
that's a dangerous thing and that's what
makes him stand out so much if you've
ever been a lady alone at the bar you
know watch out for a dude like Gaston
because you can't read alone without him
trying to be in your face it's idiots
from the moment that he walks in sure
but also he's immortal and he's immortal
and he's like not like immortal he's a
mortal in old timey times which means he
could be felled by a cold and he also
has about the same lifespan as scar does
because honestly a lion and a human that
could be felt that cold they had 20-30
years tops not only that but scar had
Hamlet and Mussolini to look at for how
he could have done better and still did
it do better Ursula on the other hand
she can honestly really come off like a
sweet auntie she can come off like
somebody that really does want better
for you and that's what makes her so
menacing
because at the end of the day she could
be patty or Selma she could just be the
old spinster living with her old cats
but she's so much more dangerous than
that I hear I hear your arguments and
again I respect your opinions here I
respect that that Ursula Gaston are are
evil but they're they're the kind of
evil characters that you love to hate
just like maybe Darth Vader in Star Wars
but scar is just he's evil you hate
hating him oh you you don't want to like
him at all again you're talking about a
character of regardless of how long his
lifespan is he let his entire kingdom be
destroyed people people animals died his
brother died he killed in cold blood he
murdered his brother no other Disney
villain especially the ones that you're
mentioning could do that so while your
choices are noble they don't top the
violence and the bloodshed caused by
scar that is you just can't top that
what makes casts don't stand out so much
I think is that his normalcy that he is
just a human yes he can be killed by a
cold but the thing is he represents
intolerance and that's something that is
very you know relatable to everyone
because that's the thing just this
normal guy but if you can get the mob
behind him and they're all shout and
kill the Beast because he just doesn't
like this guy because he's different
that's what's so awful about him so yeah
he's not trying for you know to conquer
the world to conquer the kingdom but
that's the thing is that this these
people are everywhere that but have the
same mindset as Gaston and that's what
makes him really so compelling as a
villain is the fact that right next to
you at the bar could be a guy who has
such a whole thing inside him
Gaston wants a French village Skaar
wants a pride of lions
Ursula wants the ocean there is more of
that than there's actual land the Mary
Trant we know less about the outer space
itself and ursula wants that not only
that if we're going by like villain
songs cast on good song scar incredible
song but also Jeremy Irons could
actually only do most of not I think
like 80% of the beginning of the song
and then his voice let out so actually
the voice for Winnie the Pooh had to go
in and finish the rest of the song
Ursula beginning to end poor unfortunate
souls all hurt when for Karthus of who
finished who finished that song Jeremy
Irons dialogue like he's just so
deliciously evil never trust a lion with
an English accent I said the kingdom
because obviously the oceans water makes
up 7/10 of the earth a kingdom is a
kingdom and there's something about
about about scar that is inspired by
Hitler and Mussolini and by all the
great dictators and that they were so
selfish and self-absorbed and obviously
very very troubled internally but again
when you're talking about a character
that has no remorse to kill blood shed
to have their own blood for the sake of
their own power again that is that's
something that transcends animation
final thoughts Eric please give us any
closing thoughts yeah you know thinking
back about your metaphor about the guy
at the bar yes you know Bell sees
through him because Bell is awesome but
talking about songs guests on you see it
right there
he gets that whole bar behind him so
quickly that that is what his power is
that like he is charming and funny to
some people a lot of people actually and
that is how he can get just your normal
everyday Joe those people sitting the
bar to suddenly do something awful in
his name that he can turn it all around
and the thing is that these other
characters yes it's like they're talking
animals or they're underwater creatures
that's not really relatable to us but
guest on he is very relatable to us in
all the scary ways it's like you can
think like wow I probably know a guest
on and that's really terrifying that's
what makes him stand out so much alright
thank you Eric Vanessa
the scary parts of Ursula is you know
her only motivating factors power and
nothing means anything to her so she is
unstoppable
not only that unlike scar or Gaston she
has the ability of
magic on her side and with all of these
characters there have been remakes and
the recasting have had some medium
controversy but none as big as Ursula
because that is a character that is
iconic and that is one where we truly
really care about somebody embodying
that casting and I didn't see that pop
up with scar or Gaston when it came to
their remakes recasting okay first of
all when you're when you're talking
about Disney animated movies The Lion
King is the highest-grossing Disney
animated movie of the 90s and the reason
for that is because the story because of
this biblical and Shakespearean it
transcends just being a movie for kids
grown-ups embrace this movie - and no
matter how old or young you were the
violence in this movie for a Disney
animated movie was shocking that made it
scary and that's because scar killed his
own brother which rhyme all right
wow what a throwdown this is a real
difficult choice dan Merle what's
happening in the fact zone who the fact
zone just a few things scar according to
the lion guard which was a Lion King
spin-off show after the movie was born
under the name Ascari it was bitten by a
Cobra and I'm the face that's where he
got his his signature scar Mufasa
actually gave him the name scar which
stuck resolved very tragically for that
family the concept of Disney Villains
and murder while scar did definitely
kill his brother in cold blood shame you
from Mulan also confirmed body count
Hades Jafar the the person at the
beginning in the cable wonder is also
syndrome
just a few other Disney or Pixar
villains with confirmed body count was
indeed taken over by Jim Cummings who's
done many many voices was a fun very
notable amongst them I had to take over
for Jeremy Irons after he had some some
voice issues there you go yeah good one
there you go right on thank you Dan so
great arguments all around you haven't
you all picked iconic villains great
characters
Eric I thought we leaned a little - in a
little too much into the wolf and Chiefs
sheep's clothing and why that can be an
attribute to a villain I don't know if
that vaults your character ahead in the
best villain category I mean a villain
could just like be seeping and villainy
and still be the best villain so that
didn't it just made it different it
didn't particularly make it better and
we really leaned heavily into that so
for me it actually came down to Vanessa
and Scott and this is so difficult I'm
kind of going back and forth in my head
right now yeah Vanessa like Ursula so
great as just like you know she was like
an inspiration to so many people just
because like she is a character who is
on the thick side and that is something
very cool to see in the Disney film and
there's so much rich just villainy
embodied in her but Scott the the
darkness and the how that character
resonates in regards to other literature
I you know what that really started to
sell me on the best animated villain and
yeah I got to go with Scott with scar at
the end of the day Dan with apologies to
Eric it was also between us and Scott
for me with Ursula and scar and I
actually did have gone the other way and
swayed me the most was I think everybody
sold their their villain being evil very
very bad very bad for others but what
Vanessa said that really stuck out to me
was the idea of Ursula being she could
be the old crazy cat lady or she could
be the person that is gonna ruin your
life and you don't know who she is I
think it is actually she kind of tread
the line almost right in the middle of
combining the best of Eric's arguing
about Gaston and the sort of false
pretense and Scott's was evil I think
that the Ursula combined both of those
aspects and parts of those arguments and
so I'm going with us all right we got
one one we're going to the polls
Danielle where we at
all right and right now we have with 50%
of this boat
scarred 32 percent of the vote for
Ursula and Gaston what 17 percent of the
vote other notables it was basically it
was just a Jafar versus Frodo fight on
very good Thank You Danielle so Scott
you take the point you won oh but great
arguments all around right there I love
scarfy all right we're going into
question numero dos oh so no one out
there is gonna have opinions on this one
what's the worst Star Wars film the
worst theatrically released Star Wars
film the holiday special does not count
the worst he actually released Star Wars
film and it's question number 2 gonna
start playing them to Vanessa oh okay
man what a fun one to pick from I'm
going with Revenge of the Sith because
between all three of them there are
still redeemable nuggets that I can find
in the prequel I can find almost none of
that in Revenge of the Sith it's the
least people acting like people not a
single character operates like the way
someone would speak and all of the
romantic scenes are very difficult to
get through with the first of the
prequel we have the ability to go in and
like everyone's still excited about it
right down to a lot of like performances
were more studied because they didn't
expect the negative response that they
were gonna get and with the second one
is just a masterclass and not enough
practical but even then there's still
redeemable moments - the second one as
well because we have that very lovely
wedding scene but I don't know revenge
is revenge on the Sith on the Third
Watch has the least people acting like
people
gotcha all right Vanessa coming in with
episode 3a Revenge of the Sith Scott
what do you got Oh what oh my god how
about The Phantom Menace Star Wars
Episode one a 1999 here's why that is
absolutely by far the worst Star Wars
theatrical movie first of all you're
talking about the first new Star Wars
movie in 16 years you're talking about
the first movie that George Lucas the
creator of Star Wars has directed since
1977 for people who grew up and became
movie fans because of the original
trilogy like I did so all three of those
original movies in the theaters 77 80
and 83 the prospect of a brand new Star
Wars film was better than the Beatles
getting back together or what that would
have been impossible impossible the
three dolls
the three Dulce Paul and how the toodles
toodles fights so to go into that movie
at a midnight screening the night that
it opened and to see that movie unfold
with the fake CGI with a horrible brawl
CGI is fake compared to the models of
the original trilogy Jake Lloyd as
Anakin Skywalker was terrible the
dialogue was terrible to take the
mysticism of the force the spirituality
of the force by Yoda in Empire Strikes
Back and making about something
biological midi-chlorians you are you
are defusing the magic of the original
trilogy and then just three words Jar
Jar Binks the worst character not not
just the worst character ever in a Star
Wars movie but one of the worst
characters in movie history that's all I
got all right poor Jake Lloyd around the
horn - Erik the Empire Strikes Back
sucks because new top
[Laughter]
and to the very silly title was also a
very silly and bad movie called attack
of the clones look yes there was already
the disappointment of Phantom Menace but
man did they double down with Episode
two just the main problem here is that
the core of this movie the central
storyline is this romance between Anakin
and Padme and man does it not sell
importantly this is also going to be
it's clear even without seeing render
the city oh this is very important to
why Anakin is going to turn to Darth
Vader so this is not only breaking this
movie by not being able to invest in
this romance it's breaking the entire
series because now this incredible
motivation for one of the most beloved
villains ever has just been dumped on
screen and no one cares no one's invest
in it just all these romance scenes you
were saying bad romance scenes friends
of the Sith but man Attack of the Clones
it's just so many of them and actors who
normally or good another films giving
very bad performances you can this
really shows George Lucas's limitations
with actors and the fact that he's not
good at emotional content and there's a
lot in this movie especially emotional
and also you're talking about episode 1
yes it's a big shift to suddenly have a
lot of digital but there was still a lot
more physical sets in that film than an
episode 2 I think Emma's o2 stands out
as the worst looking Star Wars movie in
the entire series go there alright let's
fight it out everybody first of all
here's what here's here's the thing
after the Phantom Menace which was just
to have your dreams and illusions and
basically your whole childhood shattered
and [ __ ] upon over and over for more
than two hours you can correct me on
that dead of running time the team Dan
cam but to to have that happen and to
just walk out of that movie at like a
two o'clock in the morning and feel so
defeated and so depressed and just so so
sad and upset there was nowhere for
these peoples to go but up and Attack of
the Clones not a great movie but not as
absolutely terrible as phantom menace
because you only have like a quick shot
of Jar Jar Binks which will
makes that movie a little bit better and
you know might Revenge of the Sith the
best of the three prequels if nothing
else for the last 30 minutes of that
movie when the stakes are high between
Anakin and obi-wan and you see them
building the Death Star you see Vader I
mean you know episode 3 ended on a very
very high note and I walked out at a
movie are you saying it was on higher
ground it was on higher ground than the
first episode one as much as their stuff
that I could tear apart - episode 1
still there's some great beautiful
moments there's amazing at lightsaber
fight probably the piece is really good
set pieces and so there's these things
in episode 2 is just lacking episode 2
it's just a murky unpleasant movie to
look at and I also say it's funny
because it's not were arguing for things
you ready to the synth yeah there's also
there's things around you the sense that
are absolutely thrilling to me as much
as some things are botched there's
things that oh wow this is really a
chilling memory whereas episode 2
doesn't have that it's just it's it's
this sort of drag it's sort of you're
looking and even even things I like like
Geonosis some of the fighting Geonosis
looks like crap because it's like wow
that's clearly a bunch of actors in
front of digital at least by revenge of
the synth they'd fix some of that like
things looked a little more incorporated
into their background so it's just
episode 2 does it has almost nothing to
grab onto yeah you think that you know
third time is supposed to be the charm
and it is also I think in my opinion the
worst McGregor performance we're getting
because he's exhausted we have the best
performance out of him in the first film
because that's when he was really
studying Alec Guinness says the way he
speaks the way he moves it was peak
excitement from him so we get the best
performance out of him in the first few
movies he has done checked out phoning
it in by the third and not only that
that's when we're supposed to see
Vader's cynicism supposed to like emerge
itself that's when we're really supposed
to see him become vader we're supposed
to be able to follow that and we can't
there's nothing there's nothing to latch
on to and so much of the you're supposed
to be having fun now is basically just
them delivering weird inhuman lines but
smiling it in a
three at times okay first of all no
matter how much we hate the prequels and
let's face it the prequels are just not
good movies but the reason that that
prevented us it actually stands out as
the best of the three I I defy you to
find any Star Wars fan who by the time
Vader became Vader and you here James
are all Jones talking as Vader that it
didn't perk them up know that the movie
ended on a higher notes and as far as
lightsaber battles there were so many
lightsaber battles in those movies and
in my opinion after the lightsaber
battle between Luke and Vader in the
Empire Strikes Back that was the
greatest lightsaber battle of them all
because of the stakes especially with
the eye of your father reveal that
everything after that every other
lightsaber battle it felt like you've
seen one late cyber battle you've seen
them all and here's the other thing they
they yeah both attack of the clones and
Phantom Menace are probably equally bad
but the let's make this your final
thought go ahead and roll it right in
the earth-shattering disappointment that
came from watching The Phantom Menace
after having your your your after having
the original trilogy
it was just a soul-crushing moment that
when Attack of the Clones came out and
that was also bad it was it was kind of
expected it was like well I guess that
was just as bad you weren't just that
you weren't as crushed because you
already were crushed with the Phantom
Menace and again three words Jar Jar
Binks alright let's go in opposite
direction Vanessa I'm gonna say it a jar
Jar isn't enough to kill an entire movie
it's not
I gave honestly there are still kids of
this generation not having any tied to
why Jar Jar is a terrible character
still enjoying him on Star Tours cuz
honestly I'm not defending Jar Jar but
I'm gonna say it's not enough to tank a
movie and if you go to Revenge of the
Sith
there's an entire character missing from
the story wait where is Natalie Portman
other than in an apartment until the end
of the movie that's a character that's
just gone forgotten about someone that's
been engaged in the adventures in the
first two movies just completely written
off in the third one gone a fundamental
character is missing in the third movie
that's not how you treat a character
that you don't know how to write for
alright just chilling in our space
apartment
would you look at the other two prequels
their highs are just higher than Attack
of the Clones whether it be Darth Maul
being awesome that lightsaber fight
being a standout or Revenge of the Sith
which has a killer performance for me
and McDormand he's just kind of amazing
you know really taking center stage
there are things about it that really
stand out say you McGregor is that I
believe the Neuberger loved him like a
brother when he yelled that to Anakin
but episode 2 it's just this emotional
pit at the center because so much of
that movie is on the shoulders of a
romance that is just not working and and
and the entire series by you know
default because it's like this is about
the fall of Darth Vader and this is new
or they're gonna really show what
happened to go that way my god this guy
says I just murdered young women and
children and she's like you know it
happens it's just all these beats just
completely don't land at all and it
really just takes even after Phantom
Menace episode 2 manages to take the
momentum away in a really impressive
manner alright good stuff ding ding that
is our second round who will take the
title of worst let's go to Dan Merle for
the facts and then go ahead and give us
your thoughts on the battle after that
sure Scott you were close midi-chlorians
the or less it's it's very complicated
George Lucas has a lot of answers for
you if you have questions about
midi-chlorians a runtime of 2 hours and
16 minutes so a trailers people would be
leaving the theater around 225 230 the
clones exercise the longest run side of
any of this the finals se 22 minutes
longer than Revenge of the seven let's
see it Scott I mean it was brought up to
the fight said who did not perk up at
James all children boys at the end of
the set
haha just I'm the person I'm showing
you know yes there's also one fell did I
feel like a lot of people were probably
yelling at their computers that wasn't
brought up in this fight I'm sure that
they were the ones that were coming up
in the chat and actually no really
really I actually would have sneak
preview because it was worse Star Wars
movie not worst movie I would have
picked last Jedi but I'm not a laugh but
that's a that's the road not taken' my
thoughts on the fight itself
I actually am gonna go with Erik I think
that Scott's argument about Phantom
Menace was so subjective to him and
looks at the universalizing was crushing
experience no I was thinking back on my
experience I was a little young I was 16
when it came out and I did have that
experience so that wasn't really
speaking to me as an argument because it
I didn't really share that viewpoint
that wasn't how I experienced Phantom
Menace so that kind of got me off for
with that argument so I think between
Vanessa and Erik Erik actually brought
up the deficits his felt a little bit
better things that that didn't quite
work the core the crux of the entire
trilogy not being there ultimately that
one way over so my vote goes to Erik and
attack of the clones you know what it
looks like we'll send in the clones
because I am picking Erik as well yeah
the emotion just the murky unpleasant to
look at and the highs are higher in the
other films I agree with all those
points valiant efforts from both of you
both hit some stuff that was really
lacking but Erik takes it from me Erik
you get my point
Danielle what does the poll have to say
well the poll agreed with 68% of it
going to attack of the clones 24% from
the Phantom Menace 7% for Revenge of the
Sith and I found a tweet that made me
really smile yes and it was project
avant on twitter who says anyone who
doesn't pick Phantom Menace or attack of
it clones as were Star Wars movie is a
cop
[Laughter]
right on curiosity how many people are
saying last Jedi there were a couple in
the chat but for the most part there
wasn't there was more people kind of
bouncing off of their arguments and yeah
about how much they didn't like there's
a lot of Jar Jar talk yeah I just a lot
of people talking about like their
arguments but there wasn't there'd be a
couple of people who were like come on
guys it's got to be the last Jedi then
everyone was like no we're not doing
that to be clear I'm not saying that out
of those movies last Jedi is a worse
movie than in other than those movies I
just remembered that it is a worse Star
Wars if we're gonna you know really just
sort of go here you know but I was going
back and forth between the Phantom
Menace and actually the other movie that
when it comes down to it dance paddle
yeah son yes they all know that the
worst Star Wars movie of them all his
Return of the Jedi man dosed and Ewoks
what's what now leader start talking
[ __ ] about baby baby oh come on
alright Scott one Eric one Vanessa
looking to get on the board let's go to
question number three here it is best
Pixar sequel best Pixar sequel is the
question and is question three let's
start with player number three Oh an
earpiece that is your birthday happy
birthday sir thank you very much and
Swan to say what better way to spend a
birthday even having a great time doing
movie I can think of several better ways
also you being a birthday boy will not
affect my judgment of this question or
anyone's here happy birthday good sir
love your brother go ahead okay so the
best Pixar sequel no question about it
the best Pixar sequel is drumroll please
it's blue a story three and here's ray
three you have the first movie that came
out in 95 launched a whole computer
animated movie moment movement you have
the second movie came out in 1999 which
which build upon its predecessor and the
brilliance of the third movie is that it
built upon the first two because when
you see Andy walk in the room and you
see that he's older you see you realize
how much time has passed how much you
have grown up since watching the Toy
Story movies you feel the emotion when
the toys are feeling obsolete and when
they're when they're facing the fire
before they're saved by the call and
when spoilers and he goes off to college
and and what he says something like so
long partner I mean it just the emotion
of that movie it just really hits your
heart if you love the Toy Story movies
the emotional impact and payoff of Toy
Story 3 is stronger than then any other
Pixar sequel and it is a movie that was
nominated not only for Best Animated
Feature which it won but it was also
nominated
for best picture whoa all right Scott
man's Toy Story three around the Hornet
Eric
so I'm naming as the best Pixar sequel a
prequel I just want to first off say I
got approval on this yes this counts
subsequent film after the first monsters
University which i think is very
underrated in general but also when you
look at Pixar follow ups because it
truly is breaking new ground other of
their sequels have basically been
variations on what's happened in the
first film with different things added
but still kind of the same story watch
University completely changes dynamic
not just the setting but the fact that
these characters are in a very different
place in their lives they're not trying
to do a boo substitute let's put them
through the same paces no this is a very
different journey for them it's having a
lot of fun it's a very funny movie that
gets to be a college comedy and Pixar
but at the same time there are some
great lessons in this movie I actually
think this has one of the best endings
of any Pixar Disney animated movie which
is the fact that our two main characters
get expelled at the end that they do not
get off the hook they don't manage to
save the day and then everything's okay
there are consequences for your actions
and I think the monsters University
managed is to really be a valuable
lesson about like yeah you can't always
work out everything that doesn't mean
your life is over
but it means that sometimes you do have
to pay the price for something bad you
did and it's got a to create a
characters at the center of it going
through this whole journey thing alright
consequences for your actions something
I am reminded of
Vanessa what do you got I have maybe it
picks our sequel that I've anticipated
more than any Pixar sequel and that is
Incredibles 2 because out of all of
these movies it checks off more boxes
than being a good seat being being a
good sequel and being a good Pixar
sequel it's also a fantastic superhero
movie it is a love letter to the genre
and Incredibles 2 did what any Fantastic
Four film couldn't do gives Sue Storm a
good story not only that it has that
amazing Michael chiquinho soundtrack it
has a gorgeous mid-century modern
aesthetic that we haven't really seen
done anywhere else other than Mad Men
and some of the best original superhero
creation and villain creation designs
that I've seen in a long time not only
that Pixar is known for its iconic vo
roles but every time Bob and Helen have
a conversation between each other they
are absolutely 100% husband and wife and
you are invested in what they're talking
about you are invested in those kids and
if you took away the first Incredibles
movie Incredibles to still stands alone
as a fantastic film all right and fight
it out okay first of all the Incredibles
2 lost Best Animated Feature or two into
the spider-verse
and monsters university wasn't even
nominated for Best Animated Feature like
you've any great though monsters
University well sure but monsters
University was just I think it's one of
the worst Pixar not only sequels but one
of the worst Pixar movies because it did
not build upon its predecessor even
though it was a prequel monsters
University was more slapstick II more
for kids it didn't have the cleverness
it didn't have the sophisticated humor
that defines most of the best Pixar
movies and Incredibles two very very
good film a very very worthy sequel to
the first movie that came out 2004 but
Incredibles 2 is it's a great superhero
movie and it's the Fantastic Four movie
that we never got just like the first
Incredibles was but it is it's if you've
loved superbear movies you'll love
Incredibles everyone relates to story
story everyone has toys everyone has
grown up and has moved on and left their
toys behind everyone feels the emotional
impact and relates to seeing their kid
all grown up and move on
the passage
time is relentless and that is clearly
laid out in Toy Story 3 you still have
that Pixar fun and Incredibles 2 though
like every fight that Jack Jack has it
that raccoon is so quintessentially
Pixar ridiculousness and it still has
that charm well at the same time going
above and beyond what you expected to
with that great villain monologue as
Elastigirl is moving through the
rooftops it elevates it knows that it's
for kids but it doesn't dumb itself down
it manages to be a hundred percent
firing on all cylinders and something
about Incredibles to that like I
definitely want to point out in terms of
like the standalone working thing is Toy
Story 3 works because you moved through
what he in Buzz's life and you needed
the first two movies to really like set
it up and have that payoff and monsters
Inc also relies on the relationships
that you've already established between
Mike and Sulley but everyone can relate
to the family dynamic everybody can
relate to where they fit in that family
dynamic whether they are the parents
whether they kids or even the villains
themselves out of all of them it has the
most relatable villains which is
somebody that feels really disenchanted
by the powers that be failing them the
thing is about both those movies I like
both these movies you guys talking about
but they so used the template of the
first movie you know it's like yes
Elastigirl gets a good story but by
giving her a version of mr. incredible
story from the first one where now
they've suffered of their roles but
you're basically kind of repeating
themselves Toy Story 3 great movie but
taking a lot of things at Toy Story 2
did both taking them out of the house on
adventure together learning about maybe
eventually having to leave your own or
even if it's under different
circumstances a lot of these themes are
variations what we thought before or
what we saw before I should say
whereas monsters University is doing
something completely different I think a
you couldn't go into monster University
not having seen monsters Inc it's a
prequel that definitely functions on its
own but at the same time of course it is
even better if you've seen monsters
ain't but it's also doing a different
journey for these characters is not
saying okay let's use a template we know
this works it's a nose but it's
something completely different while
also being very funny very clever in the
Pixar way this is a movie the crux of
which at
very end the final adventure is a bunch
of our beloved characters scaring the
hell out of a bunch of camp kids okay
here you go ahead and make your point in
then roll into your final thoughts hey
both of you have brought up how how'd
your movies stand on their own we're
talking about about sequels so the
argument of what stands on its own
shouldn't apply you're talking about a
sequel so it's okay to build on its
predecessor or predecessors and yes
Toy Story 3 did have elements of the
first two films and yes it did it did
break out but there was a darkness to
Toy Story 3 that was unexpected the
whole stuff with lots of hugging bear
and big baby little scary stuff when the
toys are facing their Mort their their
mortality you know before they almost
get burned to death you have you the the
fact that this is a sequel a third film
you are so vested to the characters that
the thought of their death is is
horrifying
in fact that that didn't happen but
again you're talking about a film that
everyone can relate to this is my
pigeonhole for superhero movies and I'm
sorry monsters University a little too
much slapstick not enough depth not
enough cleverness not enough for
grown-ups it's more just for kids thank
you Scott around the horn to Eric yeah I
just I feel like the thing is you're
under estimating about your University
because yeah it's so there's slapstick
there's humor but there's a lot of gray
Chevy there if you look at it especially
the fact that yes it's a prequel so
people think well we know where these
characters going they're gonna work and
Monsters Inc so they obviously must have
a successful college career and that's
the thing about what the journey they're
on in this movie which is basically not
only you know getting expelled from
college but the lesson at the end which
is that there are other paths you can
take in life I think this is a very sort
of lot of depth here what they're
telling you about the fact that you know
maybe you can start in the mailroom
maybe there is another thing to do it
just in everything's not gonna be easy
everything can't be forgiven and the
thing is yes sequels should build on
their predecessors but they also
shouldn't copy
they shouldn't be so beholden to the
exact sort of arcs or the exact sort of
past before so great and monsters
University I think says let's really mix
up what happens with these characters
but it's a pre very different dynamic
sorry all right thank you Eric different
dynamic Vanessa
while the movie completely stands alone
on it
it does pick up exactly from where the
first one left off answering questions
which is what we wanted of a sequel we
want questions answer we want to go on
new adventures with the characters that
we've already fall in love with and they
are new characters you can say it's
flipping the roles and Helen's just kind
of going through what bob was going
through but easy because this is an
entirely new world for Helen Helen now
has the entirety of whether or not
superheroes get to exist writing on her
shoulders and Bob that was a solitary
mission so it is a different story and
you have that charm and that slapstick
that you have with - and Jack while also
going really deep with that Evelyn
endeavour character played by Catherine
Keener who we've seen as an incredible
villain before and now she gets to be an
incredible villain for kids boom there
it is that is the end of round three
let's visit Dan Morell in a place known
as the fact zone the facts that's right
yes Toy Story 3 won Best Animated
Feature it also won Best Original Song
had nominations for Best Picture Best
sound at it sound editing Best Adapted
Screenplay Incredibles - lost - into the
spider verse which came on super strong
late in the race and took the Best
Animated Feature Oscar and monsters
diversity not nominated frozen won Best
Animated Feature that year other films
nominee where the Croods Despicable Me 2
Ernest and Celestine and the wind rises
thank you thank you for all those facts
so I thought you all made compelling
arguments this was a difficult choice
here didn't make it easy because you all
you're all smart and you said smart
things but at the end of the day the one
person who I heard the most specificity
about in regards to their movie this
isn't my choice of these three but this
was the best argument to me I thought
Vanessa just just dog-eared all these
moments characters and themes within her
movie that made her argument stand out
above the rest so I got to go Vanessa
with Incredibles - specifically like
really given props to hell
in that movie like it was good it was
her movie and just yeah that I really
appreciate where you're coming from on
that Dan where you at I really need to
Scott's comments about you know if
you're responding to the idea that it
relies in others we are talking about a
sequel so yes you you know it is okay to
certain extent for it to rely on the
other films so I didn't get quite as
much weight to the the argument that you
have to you know build on everything or
that that's a detriment however again
kind of like the first round I think
that Vanessa sort of navigated between
the two arguments of her competitors and
crafted a sequel or a good argument of
whyyy credible stew is good both as a
standalone film that doesn't require the
film before it but also as a sequel that
is a follow up the unique what it offers
to the Canon that's unique
I thought Scotland you know while it's
true that you can build off of Scotland
a little too heavily on the the if you
love Toy Story it's a big payoff thing
whereas you Vanessa underscored
additionally the stuff that was unique
about her film and I loved Eric's
passion for monsters University I think
it was just Vanessa took it for me so my
point goes to minute
Vanessa you got the point
[Applause]
two questions what does the poll say and
then how many people said planes - all
right so the polls we had 56% twin story
three Incredibles - at 26% and monsters
University at 17% a lot of people just
sharing all of their various Toy Story 2
fields yeah Toy Story I wish I was an
adult or I wish I wasn't an adult
anymore I'm gonna say this because I
think it's funny and I am NOT
encouraging you guys to do it anymore
I'm gonna do this one time because I
thought it was hilarious it's never
happening again all right Shmuel - in
the chat wrote thank you for favoring us
so with that delightfulness all right so
we are all locked up at one one one that
is a great moment in sports a three-way
tie all right let's go to question
number four here it is oh that's a
turkey
grab your stuffing and eat them up and
it's Thanksgiving next week so we are
asking in honor of Thanksgiving which
picks our character what you fight over
would you invite over for Thanksgiving
dinner it is American Thanksgiving to
our international audience please feel
free to participate in this question as
well what picks our character would you
invite over to Thanksgiving question
number four we'll go back around the
horn to player number one Eric please
start us off Thanksgiving it's a
wonderful time a family of great food
but it's also can be very stressful and
so I think you know you want to help
alleviate the stress there and that is
where woody comes in because you've got
this friendly helpful presence coming in
woody is great because he wants to make
sure that you were running a tight ship
he's gonna be there to help you at
Thanksgiving he's gonna clean up after
us make sure that there's clean about
themselves if there's clutter that you
want there as the homeowner he'll make
sure the clutter is restored has it was
when you left it you know that's the
thing is you don't want disruption and
woody is going to be the opposite of
that he's just going to make everything
better Pleasant a friendly presence that
it would be warming everyone's heart all
right that's the thing he says Vanessa
oh do you like what I wanted
Thanksgiving is someone that will not
only help out but also make sure that
every single one of my dishes are better
than everyone else's so they can really
know who's king and the person that's
gonna help me do that is Remmy the rat
is a trained French chef he's gonna have
the best turkey the best haters with the
right potato to butter ratio he's gonna
sit on my head and pilot me the entire
time and we are going to crush it
multiple courses we're going to kill it
and Remy has already shown himself to be
a very clean neat and tidy rodent it
will not be my first dance with like a
cute little fuzzy thing hanging around
during Thanksgiving because I have owned
guinea pigs before so that's not like
weird to anyone I know
not only that least amount of space and
eat the least amount of food so triumph
Thanksgiving with Remmy on your head
alright Remmy from ratatouille Thank You
Vanessa Scott if you're talking about
someone something who was eager to
please that's something he was really I
mean you talk about woody helping to
clean up I got news for you Wally will
do a much better job of cleaning up cuz
not only will he clean up he'll get rid
of the trash because that's his job
that's his purpose Wally is also quite
adorable and everybody loves Wally and
then not only do you have him cleaning
up but then what do you want to do after
you're done with Thanksgiving dinner you
want to watch a movie and Wally loves
movies while he loved classic movies so
that's a great Thanksgiving dinner for
me oh I mean what is all three great
Thanksgivings fight it out fighting out
first of all you're talking about a rat
I don't care how clean this rat is I'm
not eating anything I'm not eating
anything made by a rat you're also
talking about French a French rat a
friendship but the hell is a French chef
know about know about American
Thanksgiving and second of all what's
shot prior to the French Darin I got his
first sometimes woody could be very
annoying woody could be annoying like
the character who just tries too hard to
be so eager to please that he gets on
your nerves so Wally you know doesn't
say too much in fact he doesn't say
anything other than his name Wow he's
just there enough to be to serve his
purpose and not get in the way and again
nothing like like having someone else do
all the cleaning up on I mean all of it
and then you go back and watch a movie
what how can Wally not get in the way
when he's this big boxy thing I mean
just some small level this small get
make the turns in a small house
you know but also you stole my line
about him being a French chef damn it
with Remy but I will say who knows
American holiday better than a cowboy
then a red-blooded toy named woody he
understands he's been in a suburban home
now for decades he's been a monk you
know Wally all he knows is what he's
seen through media
Remy's over in France woody has been
amongst the people celebrating
Thanksgiving every year right so Remi
may be a Trent trained French chef but
also he hangs out with an American chef
so he has best of both worlds not unlike
multiple chefs trained here and the
French method is basically just the
old-school American method which just
means hella butter also while he's a
trash compactor that hangs out with a
roach that's not much better than a rat
that washes his hands and yeah he's
gonna clean up he's gonna put my best
dishes my best China into a solid trash
cube and then spit it out me like tada
and be an odd conversationalist
conversationalist but he's also a toy
and anybody that has a lot of little
cousins knows what he is going into
someone's mouth not only that he's
getting a haircut
what do you will be useless the second
that he touches a child's hands so I
have someone that's either gonna wreck
everything or someone that's gonna
disappear or a trade French chef that
knows how to speak English because he
also works with an American chef that's
gonna really pump up Thanksgiving and be
a friend in the kitchen because honestly
I don't need anybody else other than me
he's gonna let's go ahead to our final
thoughts with Eric Oldman oh yeah you
know I have to get past the the rodent
thing and for some people that's a
non-starter I'm sorry some of your
guests just won't accept it and then
wall-e yeah he can't join in the
conversation and he only knows things
through movies he's not gonna really be
helpful in the way you need him and has
you said he would destroy everything
even whether he wanted to or not
would he he can help out he can clean he
can contribute he's been there the whole
time in an American family seeing how
Thanksgiving is celebrated
he wants what's best for you that's the
thing is he wants what's best for the
homeowner so he will work and he
understands everything about what's
happening to completely invest himself
and make your Thanksgiving so much more
pleasant and enjoyable
Thank You Vanessa what do you got yeah
it's a rat cooking food but he's not
actually touching any of it he's clean
and he's sitting on my head and anybody
here that enjoys street food like me we
love street food but also most of us
have eaten a hotdog coming out of a
cooler with a guy who's not wearing
gloves and definitely had his finger in
his ear and we're fine with it
Wally he's gonna rake around he's gonna
he's gonna put my good cast iron in the
trash and that has years and years and
years of seasoning on it
what do you can't lift anything at least
Alex Remmy can contribute while also
being an amazing trained chef and I have
to do really none of the work whether
you're talking about
right a rat that is going to be touching
food because he's gonna be making it or
some person get buy a hot dog from I'd
still choose the hot dog over the guy
who put his finger in his ear that's
some freaking rat who made my food
second of all you're all saying like oh
you know Bollywood the story everything
what are you talking about his job is to
tidy things up to make things neat did
you see how how organized while he was
in the area that he was living and he
was friends he was a sweet sweet like
innocent that just wanted to help you're
talking about about someone who not only
would clean up by dispose of the trash
and that's what you know you don't want
to go out walk the garbage to the to the
end oh so you just want to sit down
after you've had Thanksgiving dinner and
chill out and veg out and watch a movie
and while he will take care of that -
bye all right time there it is Wow great
stuff you guys so let's go to Dan with
the fact zone and Dan go ahead and roll
it into your choice for this round I
mean these are the kind of days that I
have here in the fact zone the last
three minutes sitting here wondering
trying to figure out where was woody
manufacturer
so sorry I can't find definitive proof
that he was manufactured in China okay
we know where Buzz's manufactured but
that but where was buzz manufactured I
believe it was Taiwan hang on those seas
now you throw 50s I think he's American
yeah what is Woody's vintage I'm
thinking was is old American plastic
yeah yeah no worries no worries but it's
like it's it's out there but I don't
yeah anyway
yes Wally and does he picks up the
chassis compact city then dumps the cube
behind him so where he would dump that
cube I don't know you may need a little
guidance as far as that the classic
movie that while he likes by the way
that he watches in the film Hello Dolly
was the film that he enjoys on his
little Jawa ships there and the future
the French do not celebrate Thanksgiving
as you can imagine for what is of what
Thanksgiving is is probably not on the
everyone's the tip of everyone's tongue
in France I did find out that the the
turkey sound in French is blue good
oh you however Vanessa brought up French
method of cooking while I'm sure some of
them may I may take on Brigitte that it
would be similar to the American method
of cooking identify data that says that
the French eat four times as much butter
60% more cheese than Americans
so health butter I think would be
accurate to French food they enjoy the
butter in the cheese but they s either
the the wait it's not so much they must
have a secret I don't know the nihilism
something can't laughing so much from
all the Jerry Lewis films that they want
knowing what a balanced diet is my
thoughts on the round oh wow I mean
everyone made such good arguments for
and against like I think you almost have
to go that too taking everyone's
argument and go for personal preference
which is I'm not convinced first of all
I don't wanna when I bring my guests
over I don't want to put them to work so
ready for things like I don't want to
invite Remy to my house and be like oh
by the way you're cooking the food as
much fun and wolly to clean up like I'm
a guest doesn't clean up for me leave it
there I clean it up that's why I'm
hosting and while Eric did describe
woody doing work what are you doing this
of his own volition you're not putting
woody to work but he's deep
I appreciate somebody who's gonna help
me keep this train moving and rolling
around on time and so I'm going with
woody only because Eric made a very
compelling thing of like why he's a good
guest he's gonna help this meal go off
without a hitch and as a host I
appreciate all right Dan choosing woody
even though he doesn't have bones you
know a little bit of a different way I
think what do you might be a good guest
but I want a who's gonna this is the big
meal of the year and at this meal I have
one goal every Thanksgiving to eat until
I'm not well and the person who would
contribute most to that is Remy person
the talking rat who contribute most to
that is Remy I feel like in my personal
Thanksgiving I just want to eat
delicious [ __ ] until I feel sick Turkey
and think about my childhood yes and
I've had sides that were not great that
were a little bit oh it could use a
little more this could use a little like
you're not gonna have that problem
Remy is gonna make it just delish rich
and a decadent meal Wally
oh he's delightful woody there's snake
in my boot I'm going Remy so it's one
for Vanessa one for Harris it's 15% and
woody wood 13% a lot of people coming
through and saying that they want more
of Myr sorry those yeah from brave some
people claiming everyone want you to
take off your hat so you can prove that
you don't have a little rat in there
who's giving you all of its Vanessa to
Eric and Scott one piece now it's time
to get crazy
taking out the hats so the question is
we're asking you to pick a Disney
animated film and a director out of the
Hat and argue why that directors
live-action remake would be the best
okay all right
yes you can look don't don't just go
around the table reveal what you have
and then we will come back around and
hear your statements Eric you have the
tenth film from Quentin Tarantino the
lead
Tarzan oh cheese Tarzan all right
Vanessa what do you have I have Sophia
Coppola doing The Princess and the Frog
Sofia Coppola
Princess and the Frog live-action and
Scott I have Brother Bear directed by
David Fincher
Wow David Fincher's brother bear okay I
want you to think about casting I want
you to think about plot and then yeah
let's jump into the fund this is
question number five so actually we'll
start with Vanessa okay so I have the
offense in the Frog a movie that I
already love honestly one of my main
criticisms was we didn't get to hang out
in New Orleans enough which is already a
very beautiful film I mean very
beautiful set piece so if you Coppola
knows how to make the most of a
beautiful set piece look at Marie
Antoinette look at Virgin Suicides in
fact if you actually look towards the
end of Virgin Suicides when the town
itself starts to build humidity and it
becomes a swamp she's shown that just
using gels and general setting and tone
she can make something feel like a swamp
without having the set piece exactly
look like it giving her an actual swamp
but she has proven to make look
interesting and compelling she could do
in this she's really great at like
figuring out the inner conflicts of a
female lead and having it come through I
think a great female lead for this one
would either be sticking with me anika
Noni Rose or if we want to maybe skew a
little bit younger we can even go with
God we can even go with like it Janelle
Monae because we know she can sing so
she could do almost there and it's read
prize really really beautifully for a
doctor faciliate
who I would maybe even go with like Alec
Heath Stanfield that would be very fun
she would not only be able to really
make those set pieces shine but we would
get a more human performances out of
that those characters because tiana
spent largely most of the movie as a
frog so we would actually be able to see
Tiana B Tiana and a lot of criticisms of
Sophia Coppola tend to be that she's -
fountain which is a ridiculous criticism
ridiculous criticism and this is a
Disney princess movie and she's shown
that she can bring dark angles to really
soft things so I think Sophie would be
great on this good stuff Lear more from
you in a minute Scott what do you guys
okay so we got brother Barrett directed
by David Fincher I'm just going to go
really off the rails on this if you're
gonna have David Fincher directing your
movie
why not have it
haven't do a Disney animated version of
Fight Club live-action remake 5 action I
got coke a lie that should remake of
Brother Bear Brother Bear
and it's basically Fight Club what
better way to really take advantage of a
live-action version of Fight Club and
marry and what sort of a Disney
sensibility than to have animals beat
the [ __ ] out of each other and what
better what better director to
completely reinvent sort of a Disney
brand but to make it to so violent it
makes make take a movie that was
basically for kids and make it just for
grown-ups I know I'm just like going off
the rails here but that's all I got you
know what feel free to go off the rails
always this is always a safe place to go
off the rails there thank you Scott I'll
hear more from you Erik what director
can take any movie and give it a spin
give it his own take you take Tarantino
you take Tarzan this classic story he's
going to give you a Tarzan you have
never seen before what he looked at cast
I mean he does have certainly his
players
I say Brad Pitt yes he's older than you
expect but did you see his body and Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood he's still
rocking it so he can a play our Tarzan
and then Jane she's gonna come in it's
gonna be Zoe Belle so Zoe Belle's gonna
come in his chain because you know this
Zoe this this chain she can definitely
throw down she can definitely fight you
know of course you think about
Tarantino's language it gets a little
salty doesn't seem very Tarzan II well
that's what Jane's gonna come in I mean
she's gonna come in she's you know she's
a streetwise character she comes from
the city and you know she's gonna
introduce a lot of new things to turns
in including some you know language she
might not have heard before I have no
idea what Rosie O'Donnell's character
was that gorilla but I'm gonna say that
Tarantino brings back Rosie O'Donnell
because Tarantino likes to take actors
from the past and reinvent them so this
is gonna be Rosie O'Donnell but Rosie
you've never seen before she's gonna
really surprise people he's gonna take
her to an edgy new place and it's gonna
get of course have an amazing soundtrack
we know it's gonna have a great I'm
sorry Phil Collins your songs will not
be included this time we're gonna go
with some hits of the 70s jeans get
introduced
Tarzan to her favorite music
and then they're going to return to the
city where you know we're gonna have to
have maybe some crime get involved in
partisans gonna have to learn a few
things that alright Phil Collins will
not be in your heart or your movie fight
it out yeah I mean Tarantino has amazing
music selection but as is Sophia Coppola
I mean look at the music that was
selected for Virgin Suicides it's the
best of the 70s if you go and listen to
The Virgin Suicides soundtrack most of
that is what made it onto guardians of
the galaxy's mix like it it's expertly
curated same thing with Marie Antoinette
it's it's it's so much color it's so
much life and not just that the girl is
a Coppola think about the way what her
father did on Dracula this could be her
Dracula with it's like practical set
pieces and everything happening on
location
she has New Orleans to work with she has
a swamp to work with what she's shown
that she could do before and like
getting her hands on a villain like
facili a and getting the ability to
direct a character like Tiana who's just
so tenacious and her thing isn't really
for love it's for something that's what
she wants on her own which she has
directed with the leads and again Marie
Antoinette and once again Virgin
Suicides
it's something that she's proven capable
of being able to handle it's just a
matte an amalgamation of all of her
expertise Scott what's the first rule of
bear club don't talk about bear don't
talk about bear [ __ ] see now you know
you're talking about like music who
wants to see enough with the music here
okay if we're gonna go go big or go home
so so [ __ ] the music just do something
that's really far out and really just
shake up the Disney brand and just act
you know if you think of Disney you
think of cute animals and everyone loves
the animals and Disney movies but what
better way to just really shake it up
and have movies beating the crap out of
each other and making a social situation
making a social commentary in the
process and cause the anarchy doing away
with materialism to just shake up the
government and shake everything up and
that's what David David Fincher's
brother Bears Eric give me a little bit
more Tarzan think about it when you look
at Tarantino's recent films he's really
gone to these different environments you
know if you look at inglorious basterds
and hateful eight and Django he's taking
people it's not you know we have a
picture in her mind of what a church in
a movie is would be sort of tough guys
sitting around
showing these very different things with
that so that's the thing about Tarzana
is like he could take that this you know
jungle setting this setting that we
might not think of for a Tarantino film
but he's already shown he can take his
style and move it into these other
literal geographic places but also kinds
of movies and give it his spin so I
think that you're gonna get here it's
like I think about some of the things
even in inglourious basterds as much as
it's a world war ii film it's also these
guys going through the jungle they're
having some interesting fights
skirmishes you can take that to tarzan
but then of course you can go to the
next level because it is Tarantino and
you also go to Kill Bill and II think
about what he did with action and I
think he could really go there again
with this when he wants to go all-out
with action he does hi and we've heard
enough good stuff all right Dan let's go
to the fact zone yeah suicides
soundtrack the only song to make the
both official soundtrack albums was I'm
not in love but the same aesthetic for
the music are both though they do share
a little bit of common lineage between
the two yeah I next to Scotts I just
wrote down Scott brother bear by David
Fincher live-action Fight Club with
bears and then in quote Fight Club with
bears again doesn't really bear a whole
lot of resemblance to the plot of the
intro some people want a write in their
plot so I have a question see Burt
you've never seen brother Joaquin
Phoenix plays a young Native American
who doesn't like bears and then his
brother is killed by a bear and so he
kills a bear but then it's turned into
one himself and then he dances down some
steps yes walking Phoenix is a bear but
that his other brother wants to kill
Joaquin Phoenix's bear but that would be
bad because long story short check it
out on a Disney
many friends actual bears and the
lessons are learned because you asked
for a different movie and then your
description yeah it all came together
also you said who cares about music
oh man The Pixies where is my mind is
beautiful this one out of the water
hi Rick I could have used a little bit
more Quentin Tarantino isms I mean
that's what Ascot dropped the f-bomb you
should have been driving yeah I thought
just Vanessa just was head and shoulders
above you guys so I go with Vanessa damn
I'm inclined to agree I think that just
not quiet on board with with the bear
fight movie and elements to Eric's pitch
yeah I think Vanessa really keyed into
like here's how Sofia Coppola can take
this story the aesthetic of it
everything and really turn it on it's
make it as something special so I'm also
with Vanessa so it is Vanessa 3 Eric and
Scott one one that means we're going to
a tiebreaker well here it is it work oh
I'm sorry the poll I got so excited
about tiebreakers if you want to get her
something for Christmas you got to get
him a tiebreaker
yes all right so with 20% or 40% of the
vote it was actually Eric and then three
present for Vanessa and 25% for Scott I
got that much nice
like bears and so this is our tiebreak
question and it works like the speed
around vanessi you can sit this one out
just catch your breath you know think
about what you're gonna do later tonight
so I'll ask the question shat out your
answer then you get 20 seconds to
elaborate on your answer in the order
that you answer and then 10-second
rebuttals okay all right thank you Dan
what currently running TV series should
add the Muppets to the cast glow weave
glow Scott v for Grey's Anatomy Grey's
alright no one gave the correct answer
which is the Watchmen all right so Erik
answered first with glow 20 seconds
begin when you speak okay Khloe's a
super fun show we got 80s you got
wrestling and what is better of 80s and
fun than the Muppets Miss Piggy belongs
in that wrestling ring Miss Piggy
belongs going up against Alison Brie on
that show she can bring Janice along you
know she'll the the trip to Vegas that
is made for piggy we can get a great
road trip you know the other Muppets can
come along they show up she's really
annoyed with them Kermit and her after
workout there's fish time okay what
could be better than having Kermit the
Frog in charge of a hospital and you
have Miss Piggy it's the intern who has
a crush on the doctor and I think you've
got monster the operating room I mean
there is a whole lot of potential for a
whole lot of just craziness going on at
this hospital with a lot of puppets
doing their thing and you've got the
band they could do the house they could
do the music for the score you know
we've seen too many like parodies like a
soap opera thing you think Chloe would
get Miss Piggy she's so physical anyway
great stunts she does great Muppet Caper
this is the officer to really show off
that and go
physical and slapstick of the Muppets
are so good at okay but you want to do
something a little different here and
you would never imagine them up it's
doing a hospital TV show which is why
it'll be so fundamentally colossal II
different but still be fun just like the
Muppets all right good stuff you guys
let's start with Daniel Radford Daniel
Radford who do you like out of these two
you get onto my trick of if I just don't
look you in the eyes maybe you won't
pick me first I want to see obviously
both of these shows I think that they're
great both of them honestly like really
both of them hand John wouldn't it be
fun to see the Muppets do this and
you're both right for for different
reasons but I will say that for me Eric
got more specific when you mentioned
Miss Piggy is really physical Miss Piggy
does know martial arts Miss Piggy does
do stunts and so seeing something like
that and having that element that's
already a part of her character brought
into glow I think would be a great match
that's one for Eric and I'm gonna go
ahead go I have to disagree I think that
Eric Spitz was way too piggy centric you
had Kermit monster I heard what the band
was gonna do I grabbed this piggy was in
there too so I feel like I feel like I'm
going with Scott because I cook too much
Miss Piggy all I heard was piggy piggy
piggy
[Laughter]
great point
I'm gonna miss piggyback what Danielle
was saying and I thought it just fit in
with the world of glow a little bit
clicked a little bit more and yeah just
by a little bit of felt i I'm going with
Eric I'm sorry my father okay it is time
for the speed round the speed round
works in the same way the I will ask the
question shout out your answer the first
player to so actually we'll just go with
who gets the most because there's a
chance that we someone could win but
they wouldn't get six I'm keeping track
okay keep it check out I will I will let
you know when we're at game points okay
great thank you Dan
alright so again I'll ask the question
shout out your answer and you but there
is it but there is a chance that we
could have a winner without six points
there is yes thank you damn psycho [ __ ]
yeah points goes crazy all right let's
go ravenclaw
so again 20 seconds twenty seconds in
the order you answered and then
10-second rebuttals alright shout out
your answer for question number one
other than Yoda which Star Wars
character would make the cutest baby
rank or Keeper rank or Keeper Jabba oh
okay we heard rancor keep her first job
a second
20 seconds begin when you speak ok
record keeper means you also may be
ranked or is gonna be this great
adventure together it's like Calvin and
Hobbes always Star Wars characters
they're gonna go out they're gonna be
wearing bunk shirts gonna be have fun
we're gonna see what Jabba's like has
like you know oh
rank or keep her a little rank or you
are annoying me get out of there
it it writes itself really because all
the adorableness plus Jabba's palace it
gives you all these characters from the
bounce off of John already talks like a
baby how much more like a baby is he
gonna talk as a baby that's adorable
he's gonna be basically all eyes and
mostly texture which is already a
fascinating texture is he like jelly is
he smooth I can't tell it but I feel
like it's softer as a little itty-bitty
baby in a bundle
imagine that wrapped in a blanket so
cute but that big old mouth I just want
to throw food into it 10 second rebuttal
record keeper there's just so much more
to do there because Japanese already the
baby you okay but record keeper is
adorable he looks like a big baby
already
they just shrink them down and get a
natural thing to go off those and bounce
off of and you good job as an adult I
can't imagine that arms happened early
in life I feel like that's a later life
development so it's an armless little
itty-bitty bundle that I feel like looks
like the baby from dinosaurs and that is
already a mountaintop of cute
alright so much cute over but yeah I
gotta go with Eric and the rancor keeper
he gave us that Calvin and Hobbes
framework which is kind of delightful so
that's one Ferrara
[Laughter]
yeah these were they were both really
great pitches I do I also want to see a
little tiny squishy slug Java but I will
say and you know and maybe this isn't
very it's not quite what the question
asked but I did like that there was some
idea of not only what you know the baby
rancor keeper would look like how the
show would work so all right so Eric
gets that point did you not say wicket
it is three adorable little human
Emperor okay all right number two going
back to some Disney which live-action
Disney remake series should get a third
movie Maleficent or Alice in Wonderland
Maleficent okay okay Angelina Jolie
versus Mia watch house Petoskey
wachowski all right so we had Vanessa
first with Maleficent 20 seconds ago
when you speak Maleficent is a
completely different take on a character
that we already know and it's expertly
played by Angelina Jolie can you tell me
anything about what happened and if it
mattered in the first or second Alice in
Wonderland other than I guess Johnny
Depp is goofy and he's wearing a weird
hat we don't even really remember
anything that happens with Alice and
that's a titular character we should
care about Alice we don't care about
Alice yet in Maleficent not only do we
have the characters that we still care
about and the Alice in Wonderland
threequel has it is they can reinvent
that's the thing they can scale down
there were big battles in those first
two films there's a lot of Johnny Depp
being Johnny Depp he'd take that all
away you get back to a small story about
Alice and some quirky adventure she goes
on that doesn't have to try to be epic
that's the thing you can go back to the
core of Alice here and I think people
really enjoy that because it's like they
got a little overdone with a 3d and all
that no let's just go into the strange
world
well visit and the series that it gave
us is the only time that we really get
to explore what Aurora was like growing
up we only get a flash cut in the actual
animated movie we actually get to see
what kind of person she is who shaped
her why her values are the way they are
Alice for all its faults was a billion
dollar grossing movie people are
investing this so that's why you can
still there's still room to grow here it
just doesn't have to be what they did in
those first two films there's a lot of
things you can go with Alice as a
character that have yet to be explored
all right Dan thanks Mia Wasikowska and
I'm sure that there's many classic
animation fans who are yelling at us
Maleficent thank you this is tough I do
want my do you want my anthem I how I'm
weighing in sorry apologies I think that
the path ahead was charted more clearly
for me by Eric very slightly the idea of
a third movie being used to go in a new
direction right the wrongs versus maybe
a little bit more of what we've seen the
first couple of Maleficent movies I
think that Eric Spencer is just a little
stronger you know what Dan I'm going to
have to agree with you
he painted like just that intro like
there is so much interesting crap in
Wonderland and just like he piqued my
interest for a moan I didn't think that
was possible in regards to Alice in
Wonderland film so just for that alone
I'm going Eric three craziness all right
here is question number three of the
speed round tangled or frozen tangled
version they got what they wanted so we
heard tangled from Vanessa first Eric on
deck with frozen go ahead whenever
you're ready Vanessa
yes frozen had this song but I feel like
tangled in the end is the better movie
because not only do we get to meet more
characters but also there's something
about Mandy Moore's voice work as
Rapunzel where she's not just Rapunzel
she's not this old character that we've
seen before but she's a girl that just
wants to break out and meet adventure
and then we have Zachary Levi who's just
somebody that wants a redemptive arc we
have those great great moments in the
bar frozen has extremely lovable
characters as one of the most famous and
beloved songs ever but all the songs are
great in that film but also at the
center of it has this familial
relationship these sisters it is not
about a woman and her love of a man or a
man saving her it's not these sisters
their love their love for each other the
fact that Anna is not just saved by the
love of her sister she saves herself
because of her love for her sister it
takes everything about Disney movies we
thought we knew and it says we don't
have to do that
Olaf insists upon himself and Rapunzel
wasn't saved if anything she saved
everyone around her by giving them an
optimism that they didn't have before in
a world that told them who they were and
who they had to be forever and Rapunzel
said you can be more you know tangle is
a pretty movie but there's so few
memorable moments into memorable songs
frozen is iconic scene after iconic
scene with Anna centerpiece and everyone
remembers it just sticks with you it
stays with you and you always you can
tell that story to anyone how about it
yeah you know what I feel like there was
a little bit more passion about about
this and you both had good points but
man
Vanessa's opening argument was a little
bit hard to overcome I thought so yeah
I'm going with Vanessa and tangled
Danielle this one I getting both great
argument and I really felt that
Vanessa's passion coming through but
I've got to go with some of the points
that Erik brought up with frozen you
know the book the there was a real big
whack when he mentioned it's not just
the frozen had you know those great
iconic songs tingle songs are kind of
not super memorable and then also
mentioning how it was a way to redesign
the Disney way of doing things were
instead of it being someone being saved
by a dude these sisters save themselves
and one of them saves herself so I'm
gonna go with that all right Dan decided
oh boy yeah this is opposite with my
actual feelings that I also had
to go with Eric I think it was just I
like tangled better as a movie but I
think Eric made the better argument all
right Eric you have vaulted into a
one-point lead it's four to three points
all right
game point yeah you need this to tie it
up all right Vanessa if they made a
live-action Mickey Mouse movie who
should play him Tom Holland all right
Tom Holland Paul Rudd the correct answer
is actually Kevin Hart but uh hahaha no
or maybe not okay 20 seconds on the
clock for Tom Holland Tom Holland is
nimble Tom Holland is cartoony have you
seen the way he moves he's basically
Steamboat Willie built-in he can bring
that cartoon eNOS into that real life
aspect and he's also just so young in
fresh face that he has that like
innocent boy charm that Mickey has when
it comes to the way the world around him
reacts Tim not only that but if you look
at the way Tom Holland and Pluto adapt
has a youthful turn but he's actually
been around for decades it has a lot of
wisdom to pass on much like the
eternally youthful Paul Rudd you can
convey all of that he can convey that
youth that charm that via whimsy but at
the same time he's seen things he has
some things to pass on to people because
he actually has lived a life and learned
lessons that his friends and his loved
ones can can get from him and he could
actually learn a lot from him and that's
what makes him so perfect Paul Rudd is
too sarcastic and also like self-aware
to be Mickey he's too cool to be Mickey
Mickey is a dork Tom Holland is an
adorable dork he says the wrong things
he takes the wrong step sometimes which
is Mickey monitor Disney is always
self-aware so that's why Paul Rudd is
perfect but also at the same time he's
not too cool for school
Paul Rudd is sort of a dorky guy but he
is a lovable and a handsome dork and he
can put all that into Mickey and make
him the Mickey that we all love and more
good arguments Dan yes means something
different to Eric than he does to me
anything from Mickey the idea has this
infectious energy he's already very
nimble he has the spirit of that kind of
carefree youth and whatever already mmm
so I'm going with Vanessa Vanessa let me
over all right one for Vanessa Danielle
oh yeah I have to agree like as much as
I love like a I like what a lot of
characters do kind of a nod nod wink
wink I don't think that that's Mickey to
me Mickey screams sincerity well he
didn't call sincerity so that's so with
that in mind I'm gonna go with Vanessa
all right Vanessa you've tied it up this
is here it is who should direct Tron
three take about TD who Michael sure the
creators a good place okay we have
Michael sure we have Taika Waititi
vanessa you were first 20 seconds on the
clock whenever you're ready for take a
take is proven with ragnarok that he
could take a property that already
exists and not only make it completely
his own but put a refreshing take on it
he's also shown that he can bring a lot
of the color and the world that Tron
would need because again with Ragnarok
in his previous projects not only that
Cora gives exactly the kind of character
you did his management imagine to find
somewhere in tron where he's just been
trapped in the mainframe for years and
years and years and the Tron movies are
cool but they're also cold and that's
why I'd like you like the idea make sure
I know he's coming from TV but plenty of
people have made that transition the
Russo brothers among them from TV to
film and so you take someone like that
you look at the good place and it's got
this whimsical idea but it's also very
big idea it's actually going to very big
metaphysical places big themes and I
think they can do that with tron - it's
like he can go for the sci-fi route but
he can also give it a lot of heart
certainly some humor first of all i want
to eat i could play master computers
that's going to happen
only that but also when you look at the
soundtrack for a lot of the things that
he's worked on he's very good at
creating the atmosphere of what it looks
like Antron has survived by the glory of
its soundtrack
first of all christen valve throwing a
disc is something that would be amazing
and going on one of those cycles but
also again it's just he has such a great
pedigree behind him that he can bring it
and know that he mixes that humor and
that heart and can put that into tron
alright you know I felt Vanessa so we
were just leaning a little too much into
tyka making a cameo or playing a
character whereas I felt Eric painted
that much more of a picture of just
jump-starting this world and what the
director could bring even though you
made good points regarding what Tycho
would do like he did with Thor Ragnarok
I thought Erik just by a hair dan I
actually go the other way I think they
both sold very well on tone and prestige
so that was kind of a wash but I think
what Vanessa had was that addition of
not only tight with the taiko brings to
it as a performer but right there at the
end I think that was a good point to the
Daft Punk heads and everything else is
that Tron largely it's about Simon trek
that's something that Taika Waititi has
shown a good ear for of putting together
the oral a you are a Oh oral world
movies so I think that little extra bit
toward at the end there put Vanessa over
the top for me in a very close fight I'm
siding with Vanessa okay Danielle
decided I'm gonna decide while I'm
sitting here thinking about it because I
you know we always said look out watch
both of these I'm legitimately for very
good reasons for me this is like the
Battle of two of my faves who are my
favorites because they can combine both
of these they can combine the Big Ideas
along with being really funny at no one
else's expense along with just a lot of
heart so it really does come down to
technical things I do like Michael sheer
I think that the good place is doing a
lot of stuff I would like to see him do
make me something a little bit bigger
before he did this Vanessa had a really
good point about how we've already seen
her tackle would be able to top to
tackle that and so because of that by
like one of her green hairs I'm going
into Vanessa Vanessa well played well
played everybody took it to the limit
and Scott happy birthday sir go ahead
and get some shoutouts nobody can find
you you can find me on at Ness written
on all forms of social media Thursday
nights check me out on El Rey Network
and this Sunday if you're in Los Angeles
at the PAC Theatre at 9:30 at night
Church is having our monthly sketch show
and this month we have a special guest
Joe star for a Q&A so come join us
tickets are free on Eventbrite super
cool Thank You Vanessa
well fought well played Scott well Katie
Li TV review of movies every weekend so
catch me on Collider hosting an award
season show called for your
consideration this is our second season
we're sponsored by arc light cinemas
this year and we're doing an fic
screening series so make sure you catch
Collider videos for your consideration
awesome thank you Scott
Eric the Eric Goldman on your socials
phantom comm you'll see some articles
and the we enjoy wrestling podcasts if
you enjoy wrestling or people talking
about wrestling super cool thank you so
much well fought Dan Merle so Dan it's
gonna be frozen too isn't all the time
although I am holding out hope for a
beautiful day in the neighborhood that I
really really like but it doesn't do to
everything this weekend because it's the
kind of movie that will I think set
itself up to do well throughout the
holiday season
I agree but yeah frozen 2 is gonna be
huge this weekend that will be the
dominant number one at the box office
yes that it will be the big snowball
snowballing into box office goal could
be looking at the biggest global debut
for an animated film ever well we're in
that kind of territory we'll see
Monday charting with Dan Phantom and say
you heard it here Danielle Radford hi
tell us some things so also if you like
wrestling I have everyone has a
wrestling podcast behind us and podcast
we just moved days to accommodate the
new wrestling schedule so that's gonna
be coming out every Saturday from now
and it's called Texan sights I'm gonna
Zahn the max fun Network I've also been
doing this really fun project with
Amazon Prime videos their YouTube
channel it's called the red string where
I talk about some conspiracy theories
about movies some of them are just like
silly stuff that I make up to smashing
things together some of them are gonna
be me actually going through and talking
about like conspiracy theories and fan
things that people have and kind of
pokin embassy and if they work so I'm
really excited about that go check it
out and also you know just got wachatis
trailers so they pay me Thank You
Danielle Radford is completely dependent
on how many people watch every week so
dollar per click
[Laughter]
I want to thank everyone for watching
I'm Hal Rudd and they kicked me up Hal
Rudnick on Instagram and Twitter h al ru
d and i ck hoot-hoot hashtag owl nation
thanks everybody see you next time and
Ryan this episode was brought to you by
Verizon Wireless launching the 5g
ultra-wideband network for ultra fast
speeds ultra low latency and massive
capacity
this is 5g built right